[Music]
this guy came up in my feed because we
cover
we cover brendan so
brian has his dude on on his thick boy
network apparently
um there are actually other shows on
this team yeah
dude
trust me
no i'm a community i'm a surprise as you
are so there's this dude named mark
harley right
now some of you might know who he is i
don't like this this guy was someone
that i don't know who it is keep in mind
i only started following all these la
comic weirdo people because of the
brennan stuff and how dummy is i never
really cared even when i was really i'm
i'm more of a new york comedy guy i've
always been you know i prefer that kind
of comedian but whatever was different
but this um
this guy's name is mark harley and and
they've been calling him brendan's
wingman and i was wondering why they've
been calling him brennan's wing man
because i i don't i don't know
so this dude uh this is another another
streamer put some clips together and i'm
gonna play some of his videos of course
you guys subscribe to him it's uh gordo
franz
f-r-a-n-z g-o-r-d-o-f-r-a-n-z
gordo franz i'll subscribe right now
live too
um
because he had some pretty good
information about this dude i didn't
know who he was
uh his name is mark harley let me give
you a little bit a little bit of a
background then we'll go a little bit
more into him okay date for you all in
today's video i really thought this
whole brendan job situation was finished
up but it turns out his goons are after
kalila and the tiger belly team still so
i wanted to make a quick video about it
and to provide some context here's a
quick clip from the tiger belly episode
featuring brendan schaub where kalila
alludes to brendan's friend slash
assistant slash wingman mark harley who
had been sending some dm first off
before we even press play why does he
look so weird
right l.a he looks like if
chris cornell took too many steroids
no he looks like a middle schooler made
a new character in gta online oh my god
you're right yep yep
comes online so let's have a listen i'm
starting to see screenshots on instagram
of dms of your cute little friend mark
confirming that you wanted to expose me
i went to mark and said dude you're
making things way worse for me okay
because he's trying to defend me i went
you're not defending me you're making it
worse giving her fuel and me and her are
talking you don't worry
chad said he looks like a [ __ ] brad
pitt like sucking dick well it looks
like it looks like they did a modern
reboot of of of the wizard of oz and
that's what the cowardly lion would look
like like jason mammal would play him
[ __ ] jason momoa asked the cowardly
lion yeah
i didn't mention this interaction in my
previous videos because it sounded like
it was over and that brendan had talked
to mark and told him to stop making
these types of comments
it looks like it looks like they
rebooted an interview with a vampire and
jason momojo was playing brad pitt's
role oh my god first off i'd watch that
i'm not gonna lie to you watch it in a
while it would be the funniest movie to
watch but i would definitely watch that
movie
and but news flash mark hasn't stopped
despite brendan's wishes they also went
on to defend as you heard there that
mark guy was the one that was trying to
defend brendan you know to
all these other people and brendan told
him bro stop you're making me look bad
and of course he didn't so my friend
brendan in his drama situation in which
i believe one hundred percent he's in
the right and i don't know john coleman
and brad pitt walk into a teleporter
[Laughter]
ron pitt
brad perlman
wrestler number two that's not okay
that's a generic creator wrestler fair
enough that's actually very funny by the
way but in his alternate costume we use
in one of those street fights in wwe no
mercy
create a character from that playstation
2 smackdown game yes exactly
continue to defend him for reference
mark is the host of the haters will say
podcast which is actually a subsidy of
thick boy studios so he is kind of
suckled up to brendan here and he
definitely has monetary incentive to
defend brendan and in one podcast so
wait brendan didn't just start a thick
boy channel he's trying to start his own
network
apparently
why
does he know he says he started okay
you're right i forgot he's [ __ ]
sometimes
he went on to basically say that brian
and brendan didn't actually bully bobby
lee and kalyla and that they only
apologized for wrongly saying that they
were involved but they didn't apologize
for bullying at all which is obviously
silly and in the comments section he got
ratioed in that video which really isn't
surprising so yeah
he he's been going after like defending
brendan now keep in mind i i'm you were
reading the bio of this guy right
and we were we were making fun of him a
little bit but where did he go what's
the college he went to guys because you
looked it up from
the san francisco comedy college so it's
he and this is not a lie he said he went
to this gentleman went to the
san francisco comedy college let me show
you the san francisco comedy college's
website guys walking to html one this is
san francisco comedy college you know
you're right let me zoom in a little bit
because you know it's just black text on
white font here uh is the the san
francisco comedy college is the most
uh is the is the most attended stand-up
comedy school in north america
are you screaming sorry celebrating a 23
year san francisco
stand-up comedy training online in
person
learn to be funnier find your voice meet
funny friends be more personable in
business in life a little abstract all
classes with a funny money-back
guarantee
uh upcoming in person oh so you you
could be this so this guy
[ __ ] meathead that he is
this this [ __ ] meathead that he is
wanted to be a comedian even though what
he is is a bodybuilder for what i'm
assuming it's what i'm reading right
he's a bodybuilder
um and then he wants to be something
more than that because
the reason you see people that are
bodybuilders like this trying to be
comics is because think about this man
if you're any normal person or any meat
head and you see that brendan chop gets
a showtime's past you're like [ __ ] it
why not me right it can't be that hard
so um i figured we watched a little bit
of a show i've never
seen this uh never heard about this guy
until today i'm so sure some people some
of you have i haven't
but i also
skimmed through this 38 minute video
because i actually wasn't asked these
two because they were with me before the
show i stopped talking for a while
because i was so intrigued
yeah well this guy talks like
you know when a stupid person tries to
sound smart
like like they don't know how to be
smart the only thing they know how to do
is like repeat what
repeat the cadence
and and and like the phrases that smart
people use so just try to do the sam
harris
basically here
so by the way it's called haters will
say we're the haters in this situation
so just let you know we're going to be
the haters we're playing the haters okay
all right cool all right
by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and today
so he's going to come out of the gate
with a he-man reference all right that's
a strong start right
strong start all right what else give
him a chance
i'm trying i'm really trying to be fair
it might be a sad day because um
there are some rumors swirling online in
the metaverse that uh i've taken an l
and i have to be forthright with you i
have to be honest i have to come clean i
have to speak my mind in an unfiltered
manner so that you what i'm going to do
is i'm going to over enunciate my words
and make big hand gestures because they
taught me this at the san francisco
comedy college that you have to be
expressive yes and
i mean hey
he's certified man [ __ ]
he's got a degree it's gotta be [ __ ]
the right way to do it right great
degree no yeah from the san francisco
comedy college yeah dude
degree or certificate
well you say certificate i say degree i
mean whatever tomato tomato at that
point it it if it's from
the [ __ ] san francisco comedy college
it could be a [ __ ] doctorate it's not
worth [ __ ] that's a good point
you could call it whatever the [ __ ] you
want
it doesn't matter
now and in the future
and how about we call him chris swalnell
i just want to provide full transparency
i i i don't want to dignify that that's
my work
that's that's so far what i'm going with
so you guys give me a better one okay
the haters have in fact won ah
say
he's going to be a badass sweet cutaway
bro yeah
yeah the guy told me yeah yeah so
virgie and i are looking better now
right
you guys look like [ __ ] rocket
scientists okay so don't you worry about
it it ain't so mark
believe me casey i don't want to admit
this however
haters have been saying mark you're not
going to do a full-length episode this
week because you're too busy doing all
the things that you're involved with
and you might have to cut it a little
bit sure you might have to not do a full
hour or near hour so you're only doing a
40-minute episode are you going to spend
10 minutes of that episode talking about
how you're only doing a 40-minute
episode
yeah at least have some dignity and
don't show up like merch
at first my instinct was to deny oh
that's right is mercy here frozen ended
up picking up dick thank you yeah he was
he just was late because he was out
picking up dick thank you try this and
say
no way i'm doing three hours today
thank you no no no thank you merch we'll
have that after the show thank you yes
the rest of the episode with my [ __ ]
yeah okay keep it there for now yes
that's okay we're good let's i want to
watch more of brendan's wingman
boys and hopefully nobody would notice
but that's
something that i simply can't live with
i can't sleep at night knowing that it's
probably the apnea from all these
steroids you use
my guess
i attempted to deceive my listening
audience i attempted to deceive my
listening audience look please don't
notice that i'm a meat head nobody
noticed that i'm just a [ __ ] muscle
head idiot
and i fell for the scam at san francisco
comedy college
i can't say it without laughing
you know it'll get you popped but just
everybody picture in your head
the eye of the tiger yeah
over top of this [ __ ] i swear to god
oh no no i i actually have an i o tiger
we can't play
okay yeah uh what i have is i have eye
of the tiger 8-bit
and uh we could play that here it is
[Music]
actually you know what let me see if let
me see we got a shitty flute
yeah [ __ ] flute cover of the eye of the
tiger
wait a second wait a second
wait a second maybe maybe
[Music]
all right somebody gave a good counter
in in the chat too if we can't find
recorders there's absolutely got to be a
kazoo cover
here it is
we got it
so
i'll come up front and just say it
i took an l today because i am going to
san diego la factory san diego where are
you at i'm going to be there with the
trash panda tour no no you're not you're
not doing stand-up though right
but because why are you going to the
laugh factory does he have stand-up i
looked on youtube i couldn't find one of
his stand-ups yes i am leaving in a
second and we are pressed for time why
because i think he likes to do well roy
she'll play it later never mind yeah i
know was i out last night
at the one press uh one championship
press conference right after work then
went to the improv taking pictures doing
the damn thing
am i angry about that no did i get up at
5am to go train somebody god
holy [ __ ] somebody how did none of us
see this uh
kaijuko shay [ __ ] it in chat said ben
stiller from dodgeball
yes globo gym
oh my god yes there it is
yep there it is
six yes i did
and those are the kind of decisions i
make that makes me bleed my own blood
perhaps leaves you pressed for time
perhaps
gives you suboptimal sleep and sleep is
important however i find myself not
regretting those things because
i've conditioned myself to anticipate
how am i going to feel by the end of the
week let's say going to san diego you're
in a different city
ahead for giving the guy an opportunity
jacob
very good on you for crushing it hope to
see you again or uh he had us do a lat
pull down
does that say bro science academy yeah
he's teaching how to get swole
maybe we should start san francisco
bodybuilding college or something
[ __ ] why not go scam people the way
you got scammed no rice rice what
if we do that we're just going to get a
bunch of gay guys
in san francisco let's do the san
francisco school of giving me your money
you [ __ ] mark it'll be the ground
zero epidemic start of a monkey pucks
outbreak in san francisco exactly if you
open up a san francisco
bodybuilding school it'll just be a
monkey festering monkey pox hole
down [ __ ]
three weeks after you cut the ribbon and
there would be [ __ ] gay cronenberg
monsters running around the city
they already have though they're called
trans people
imagine you're sitting in a lab pull
down then reverse it
so
you're facing backwards wait i'm going
to skip ahead does it put your body
a little bit of both okay
you've seen my instagram of course i'm a
male model and
what did he just say
something dumb
i think you should rewind that did he
just say
these people they all the same brand
this is exactly
exactly what one of bren what a brendan
schaub hanger honor would talk like this
makes perfect sense to me
got him no seriously am i even wearing a
shirt right now that's how comfortable
this thing is now i was at the one
championship press conference last night
getting compliments left and right like
are you a male model or you just wear
really nice clothes if it's your body
perfectly and i'm like well a little bit
of both okay
someone said that to him totally that
happened hey royce that happened
i would say are you like a bad guy from
goldeneye
his face is a 64 game that's what i mean
like his head is shaped like he's
polygons
are you [ __ ] you're 64 bits of a [ __ ]
podcast buddy i don't know why you're
[ __ ] listen i get it man you think
that you're gonna hang on to brennan
look man that's a sinking ship let me
help you out here here's what you gotta
do stop trying to do comedy
number one that's the most important
thing yeah you're not good at it yeah
number two
pick
pick what you want to be
you're too many things you want to be a
motivational speaker you want to be a
bodybuilder you want to be a comedy guy
you want to be a podcaster you
you want you want a [ __ ] looking like
an 80s villain from a schwarzenegger
movie
you gotta [ __ ] pick a lane bro
you've seen mine and also really rain
energy drink ex i don't respect anybody
that drinks that we know man we drink
bangs up in this [ __ ]
oh or c4s are fine too
instagram of course somebody says
ghost not now yeah ghosting the show
oh jeez
well why didn't you put that one up on
the t [ __ ] four i'm [ __ ] more
obvious damn it
that's what i do dime piece
dime piece royce add it again i'm gonna
take bread and stuff
dime piece
oh and of course my exclusive contract
is with oakenstoneclothing.com now wait
a second he's doing a 40-minute podcast
and 15 minutes of it is live reads
god that reminds me of my sponsor
mybookie.ag
oh [ __ ] if you go there right now and
you use promo code rtc they're going to
match up to a thousand dollars and my
books
yeah up to a thousand they're gonna
match you up to that and it's crazy
because people that just sneak in live
reads in this stuff it's kind of really
shitty and my boogie daddy
yeah my book is that age my bookie.ig
has never made me sneak live reads into
anything i'll promise you that they
haven't but they did say royce tell you
what tell your listeners to use promo
code rotc and they're going to get like
i said up to a thousand dollars and some
credits and you can bet on the [ __ ]
fast-paced wnba do you like fundamentals
and layups then you're gonna love the
wnba and bet on my bookie because the
only thing better than women crying in
basketball is you making money off of it
mybookie.ag
this is hot off the press live i just
got i was not a live read i don't do
live reads that's disgusting to just
sneak one in yeah it's packaged
that was a
hell of a genuine conversation i had oh
the genuine conversation blue scoop neck
shirt last night i love the way it fits
i love that because my traps are so big
because of my traps are so black i hate
these guys
bro who talks like that
even if you're jack
even if you're jacked right even if
you're a [ __ ] great example trenton
wade is [ __ ] jacked okay
i've never heard trenton go blue cup
[ __ ] jerked on you like joking up but
never just been like look at my traps
dog look up i don't know why i'm doing a
black voice because he's black probably
and i'm racist i don't know but my point
is
what is your bra oh god these are the
dudes this is why they don't remember
when brian callan and brandon came after
us all they could say was oh they don't
play sports because that's your world
man
you you [ __ ]
you you know you have on your thick boy
network somebody who went through the
san francisco school of comedy
hey
he has a masters sir
great royce
that's what's going to happen now
trent's going to well he's already seen
it now uh he's going to see this yes and
he's going to start cutting promos on
this guy tagging i would trenton i want
you to start cutting promos on
mark harley
i forgot his name brendan brendan
schub's wingman mark harley he's very
forgettable yeah he really is he really
is turns out he should have went to
[ __ ] marketing school my only
recommendation is trenton is when you
when when you make these promos if
you're doing it at night smile so he
could see you
uh trent it's at hella mark harley yes
thank you trenton and thank you mark
harley we're going to be looking i i
think we're done for now we're going to
look in a little bit more this will be
an ongoing series i just wanted to kind
of introduce people to him you know what
i mean
kind of get a little
more about why this guy i have a feeling
this guy could be the next brennan in
terms of being stupid
um i really i know that's a high bar
right i understand that but from what
i've seen
from what i've seen
it's possible
all i'm saying is that i really truly
believe it's possible